hey 42 here if you're anything like me
once you get past 30 you start to notice
all the new parts of your body that are
trying to kill you your ears and eyes
stop working your knees decide to stop
bending and your reflexes become so slow
you could be jumped by an actual oyster
and then it comes
and it just gets everywhere I'm
talking about hair hair Sprouts from
your ears from your nose your back on
your fingers on your toes and on that
weird in between part we don't talk
about but we all know is there
and somewhere in your 50s or 60s you
start to put things where they don't
belong your grandchildren visit to find
you stashed a jam in the toilet your car
keys are in the fridge and you started
brushing your teeth with foot cream
[Music]
it's a fact of life that we all steadily
fall apart and slowly become absolutely
useless until we die but what
if we didn't what if aging and death
were simply optional something we could
choose to do if we wanted to but
something we could also choose to
prolong
such a possibility would have profound
implications for Humanity we could
establish colonies in distant galaxies
initiate Interstellar Commerce and
finally discover if the Milky Way really
does have a soft nuggety Center
Unshackled from the mundane needs of
sustenance or survival in time we'd
become gods
but as it happens we don't need to wait
for some far-flung future in which
humans can live forever because some
denizens of planet Earth already can
now before you go and empty your life
savings into some dodgy sounding Eastern
European startup promising to cure aging
using the blood of vanquished children
or whatever I should point out that this
ability to defy death exists
predominantly within jellyfish and if
you do happen to be a jellyfish firstly
I'm pleased to see my channel is finally
reaching new demographics and secondly
there's only one single species of
jellyfish that can live forever it's
known as toritopsis Dorney but because
that's unnecessarily wordy most people
simply call it the immortal jellyfish
[Music]
surf shark VPN keeps you safe and
private by covering up everything you do
online and surf shark VPN lets you
travel the world virtually by changing
your virtual location or if you are
physically traveling surfshark also lets
you connect via your home country so you
don't miss out on all your home Comforts
such as streaming video content from
home that might be blocked whilst you're
traveling there are over 3 200 servers
in 100 countries so anywhere you go
you'll find a server that fits your
needs I love search vpn's multi-hub
feature that lets you put two VPN
servers between you and your online
destination for even more privacy and
security and I'm also a big fan of
surfshark's Ip Rotator feature which
constantly changes your device's IP
address without losing your VPN
connection it's really important to stay
safe online when you're out and about
and that's why I use surfsharkvpn so I
can for example access my online banking
safely even on public Wi-Fi something I
would never do without a VPN vpns also
keep your location and download history
private so you can send them receive
file securely quite simply surf stock
VPN is an essential tool and by using
the Code 42 you'll benefit free extra
months for free all you have to do is
click the special link in the
description below so don't miss out and
a big thanks to Surf shark for
sponsoring this video
in the early 1990s Italian marine
biologist Ferdinando bayero was
conducting Research into tornatopsis
Dorney jellyfish in the waters around
the island of Elba when he made a
remarkable discovery
he was trying to figure out how they
reproduced when he noticed something
strange some of the adults in the
population were shrinking and turning
into Blobs of tissue that looked a bit
like a polyp the stage of a jellyfish's
life cycle that precedes adulthood now
this was a big deal not just because
Bolero had stumbled across something
nobody had ever seen before but because
as I'm sure you'll appreciate adults
turning into babies is not something
that happens in nature except on very
Niche porn sites yet here this strange
jellyfish was putting all that effort
into growing up only to regress once
again into his childhood form
even stranger it didn't just do this
once but erdo observed this bizarre life
cycle over and over in the same
specimens a single jellyfish would grow
up then grow down grow up grow down over
and over again seemingly forever
foreign
to understand how this remarkable
transformation Works let's start at the
beginning
toritops's door and I begin life as Tiny
larvae floating in the ocean after a few
days they attached themselves to the sea
floor and then to the polyp stage of
their life cycle
over the coming weeks the polyp grows
and eventually splits into separate
segments each maturing into a fully
grown Medusa the adult form of the
jellyfish
now that's a fairly standard life cycle
for a jellyfish but turretop's Dawn eye
has a little trick of its slimy sleeve
you see once it's reached adulthood if
the jellyfish is exposed to certain
environmental triggers like changes in
water temperature or the presence of a
predator it will begin to revert back to
its polyp form
starting the cycle all over again
[Music]
because scientists are psychopaths in
one experiment they cut the Bell which
is basically the body of adult specimens
using scissors
after being cut open the jellyfish would
revert to their polyp form then mature
once again with a brand new undamaged
bell and sorry I couldn't resist
as you can probably imagine this has
some pretty significant implications for
the survival of the species a jellyfish
that can live forever doesn't need to
worry about reproducing it can do that
whenever it feels like it and whilst
your average jellyfish will typically
spawn once a year tour tops his door and
I can do it whenever it likes in fact
it's been known to spawn multiple times
a month
but the immortal jellyfish isn't
actually biologically Immortal there are
very few known creatures on this planet
that are
one such creature is the Hydra the Hydra
is a small freshwater organism known for
its ability to regenerate itself when
cut in half
belonging to the phylum Nigeria the same
group as jellyfish Hydra has long
fascinated scientists with its capacity
to maintain its telomere length
throughout its life telomeres are the
protective ends of chromosomes which
typically shorten as organisms age
eventually leading to death but in Hydra
these telomeres remain unchanged Through
Time granting it a unique kind of
longevity hence we classify them as
potentially biologically Immortal but
more research is needed
[Music]
the immortal jellyfish however is a
little bit different in that it does age
it just ages backwards when and if it
feels like it and that's a pretty
important distinction because whilst
animals that exhibit true biological
immortality like the Hydra and
potentially others don't actually age by
the dictionary definition of the word
tornatopsis Dorney does and that means
it can die if it I don't know wakes up
particularly depressed one morning and
just chooses to not de-age itself in
time but the fact that it can de-age
itself in the first place is nothing
short of remarkable so then the obvious
question is how how does it do it
well the short answer is we don't know
and the long answer is we really really
don't know truth is the ability to defy
death is one of the greatest mysteries
in all of science despite the fact we've
been dying for literally thousands of
years we still don't really know why I'm
strictly talking about age-related death
of course if someone catches a stomach
bug and just shits himself to death and
that's pretty self-explanatory there are
plenty of theories of course some
scientists believe aging is the result
of genetic programming others think it's
caused by accumulated damage to
ourselves over time
and whilst those theories may sound
kinda similar they're actually very
different genetic programming would mean
we age because we're supposed to while
cellular damage would mean we age
because we're not supposed to there's a
lot of evidence to support both theories
but there's also a lot of evidence to
contradict them too and that's the
problem we can see the effects of Aging
all around us but we still don't really
know what causes it so to State the
bleeding obvious here if we still don't
know why organisms age forwards we've
obviously got no bloody clue how the
immortal jellyfish manages to age in
reverse based on Research to date it's
thought that the key to this remarkable
ability lies in the jellyfish's cells
specifically they exhibit a process
known as transdifferentiation which
basically means that its cells can
transform from one type to another
seemingly it will but the immortal
jellyfish is the only adult creature we
know of that can perform
transdifferentiation which means that
jellyfish scientists specifically
invented that word and made it stupidly
difficult to say just so educational
YouTubers like me would have a bloody
hard time pronouncing it when talking
about this goddamn jellyfish
anyway rants aside regardless of how it
works the implications for the immortal
jellyfish are fairly obvious since it
can essentially live forever it doesn't
need to worry about life-threatening
injuries it just reverts to a polyp
respawns and then tries to kill
Millennia again for the thousandth time
all of which is why in the last couple
of decades the immortal jellyfish has
spread to pretty much every corner of
every Ocean on the planet but that's not
to say tornado tops as dawnai is
Invincible for one thing its remarkable
ability to age in Reverse only works if
it's in Peak physical condition if it's
weak or malnourished it won't be able to
pull off the transformation and it will
just die like any other jellyfish in
fact there's plenty of things that can
kill tonatopsis dorneye
to jellyfish after all and it's made of
95 water so unsurprisingly it's
vulnerable to being eaten by anything
that fancies it
it's also sensitive to changes in
temperature salinity and water pollution
and it can be killed by disease or
parasites
but tonatops's donut has a few tricks to
keep it safe for one thing it can clone
Itself by splitting in two which is
always handy if you ask me it's also
able to revert back to its polyp form
pretty much whenever it feels like it
which is really useful of the conditions
in the ocean are just getting a bit
hairy not only does the polyp form offer
better protection against predation it
can also survive for several weeks in
this form without a meal but the polyp
form is obviously much less mobile than
the adult Medusa so if it switches to
the polyp form in a particularly risky
area with lots of predators around it
might not live to regret it
if you're a regular viewer of this
channel you'll know I've done a few
videos on living forever and the fact is
it's probably not all it's cracked up to
be for one thing it's pretty boring and
whilst it's true that tornado tops is
Dorney doesn't exactly have a lot going
on in the brain Department its life
isn't what I'd call stimulating in fact
it's thought that the immortal jellyfish
sometimes reverts to its polyp form just
to give itself a break because being a
jellyfish is actually quite hard work
it's a filter feeder meaning it spends
the majority of its time swimming around
with its tentacles spread wide filtering
tiny particles of food from the water
not exactly titillating is it and that
requires a lot of energy so every now
and then it just turns back into a
squidgy infant because it needs a spa
break
so if this simple organism can age in
reverse why can't we Research into the
genetic and cellular mechanisms that
allow tornatopsis Dorney to de-age has
only just begun while some scientists
hope that we'll uncover insights into
our own aging processes there are if you
hadn't noticed significant biological
and genetic differences between humans
and jellyfish that could make direct
applications of these findings rather
challenging
besides if you really want to observe
adults turning into babies today you
don't need to wait for science to
Prevail simply visit any Walmart on
Black Friday thanks for watching